will you play Hans if the opportunity
arises well right now that's not in the
near future for me I think fortunately
why not uh well because the there's
maybe only one tournament that I'm
playing in that he could be playing in
potentially and it's not even set to be
happening at the end of the year there
might be like a world Blitz and Rapid
Chess Championship so I don't think I'm
gonna have to make that decision for
about six months challenge much you're
one of um you're
the most famous super Grandmaster
in terms of online
so it makes sense in terms of Chess is
going through a kind of
like a serious controversy since it's
not just like
um the drama or something like this this
is in part in existential threat to the
game in terms of how the public
perceives the game yeah so if the story
that lingers from this is chess is full
of cheaters like you never know who's
cheating or not that's not a good uh
that's not good for the game so it makes
sense for a high profile person to to go
head to head how do you think you do
against us
I mean I I think I I think I would
probably beat him in Blitz and rap but
classical is a whole different question
altogether I think in Blitz and Rapid I
would I mean one thing actually that was
very telling in both the report and also
hans's interview for all the other stuff
it was said is the one thing he did say
and seemed very adamant about was the
fact that he had never cheated against
me which uh so that was the one thing he
did say that at least according to the
report was truthful so it's something
possibly down the road to consider
um but I do want to see what happens
with everything else first with fide and
their their whatever they they choose to
do in regards to Hans and Magnus
um and and then see where see where the
smoke stands but I think also one other
thing that is potentially very dangerous
about the whole situation is that I'm
not convinced that fide actually is the
ultimate say in this in that the top
players if they if they feel that he has
shooted over the board even if there's a
report that says he had that Hans has
not cheated top players can still decide
not to play him and sort of override
what whatever ultimate decision feed it
comes to so that's also why it's very
unclear
um you know this term of the U.S
Championship Hans qualified he's playing
the tournament but beyond this there are
no tournaments where he's automatically
qualified to and so it also is on the
top players to sort of have to reach
some conclusion on their own separate of
feeding